und jetzt das heute
journal schönen guten Abend Taktik und
Strategie sind wichtig im Sport wie in
der Politik eine Taktik von denen die
gegen die AFD sind ist nicht jeder
menschenfeindlichen Aussage
Aufmerksamkeit geben eine Strategie ist
die Partei zu isolieren oder sie
inhaltlich zu stellen wirklich
funktioniert hat davon bisher relativ
wenig die Zustimmungswerte zur fd sind
hoch wird sich nun aber am Umgang mit
der Partei durch das bekanntwererden
eines Treffens mit Rechtsextremisten
etwas ändern die wehrhafte Demokratie
war heute jedenfalls Thema im Bundestag
und ist es auch weiterhin auf den
Straßen von Verteidigung und Angriff
berichtet Christiane
hübscher sie lassen nicht nach Flagge
und Gesicht zeigen gegen die AFD für die
Demokratie 3000 sind es hier z.B am
Abend in Mainz die AFD gibt sich
gelangweilt nennt die Enthüllungen
übertreffen mit rechtsextremen erneut
eine hinterhältige Kampagne hinter allem
stecken nur die Angst der Ampel vor der
Abwahl da werden s jetzt kleine private
Debattierclubs zu gemeinfährlichen
Geheimtreffen aufgeblasen wie
verzweifelt muss man sein um auch daraus
eine Kampagne gegen die AFD zu
konstruieren wie sie das heute wieder
versuchen kleine private Debattierclubs
das recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv hat
nachgelegt und einen weiteren afdler
entnt auch Mario Müller Mitarbeiter
eines
Bundestagsabgeordneten war bei dem
Geheimtreffen dabei wo die
millionenfacher Ausweisung diskutiert
wurde so sehr sie auch abwiegeln wenn es
um rechtsextreme Vernetzung geht Herr
Baumann nichts davon ist harmlos nichts
davon ist bürgerlich und nichts davon
dürfen wir dulden meine Damen und Herren
nichts davon der ostdeutsche CDU
Abgeordnete am Tor stört sich auch an
dem historischen Vergleich den die AFD
gerade immer wieder missbrauche dann
heißt es DDR Methoden DDR 2.0 es ist
eine geschichtsvergessene Relativierung
dass Sie unseren freiheitlichen
Rechtsstaat vergleichen mit einer
staatlich organisierten
massenüberwachung gegen die es keinen
Rechtsschutz gab auch im thüringischen
Gera wird am Abend demonstriert gegen
eine Veranstaltung mit dem AFD
Landeschef börn
hö fragen wir noch mal nach bei Diana
zimmermann hauptstadtstudioleiter für
uns in Berlin schön guten Abend makige
Worte haben wir da gerade gehört aber
was folgt denn ja die makigen Worte sind
natürlich schon ein Zeichen dafür dass
in der vergangenen Woche ein kleiner
Ruck durch das Land gegangen ist
Monate vor drei Landtagswahlen im Osten
wollen die Parteien nun die AFD stärker
inhaltlich stellen wollen stärker darauf
abheben welche Differenzen es gibt
zwischen dem Programm der AFD und ihrem
Abstimmungsverhalten wollen zeigen wie
stark das Land und die Wirtschaft
beschädigt würden durch eine Politik der
AFD mehrere Redner haben auch darauf
hingewwiesen dass man insgesamt
respektvoller im Bundestag miteinander
umgehen sollte das war allerdings nur
von kurzer Dauer Ampel und Union warfen
sich gegenseitig permanent vor am
erstärken der AFD schuld zu sein bleiben
wir noch mal kurz Diana bei den
Vorwürfen unter anderem von denen des
Oppositionsführers also Friedrich März
da ging es dann um schlechte
Politik ja das hat ihm wiederum den
gegenvor eingebracht dass er selbst eine
solche Debatte wo es um die Gefährdung
der Demokratie ging dafür nutze
politische Punkte zu machen und
tatsächlich steckt aber die Union in
einem Dilemma einerseits muss sie die
Ampel kritisieren und findet auch
reichlich Anlass dazu andererseits ist
es natürlich so dass Sie sich von der
AFD thematisch und auch im Tonfall
deutlich unterscheiden muss in der
Regierung dagegen scheint man zu denken
dass die schwierigste Phase des
Regierens nun vorbei sei seit heute
Abend steht der Haushalt 204 24 man hat
sich auf eine verschärfte
Migrationspolitik geeinigt in der Ampel
überhaupt heißt es von dort die
strittigsten Gesetzesvorhaben sein nun
verabschiedet jetzt komme die Erntezeit
die Zeit in der die Wähler erkennen
könnten dass die Ampel das Land auf
Modernisierungskurs gebracht habe
Zuversicht ist ja eines der
Lieblingsworte des Kanzlers mit der kann
man allerdings auch allein sein Diana
vielen Dank für die Einordnung in die
Hauptstadt Zuversicht kann man auch
durch das Wort Hoffnung ersetzen und
Hoffnung hatten die Landwirte nämlich
dass sie durch ihre Proteste das Rat der
Entscheidungen noch mal zurückdrehen
könnten und ein bisschen ist das ja auch
passiert denn bei der kfzsteuer ist die
Ampel eingeknickt aber was den
Agrardiesel anbelangt da gibt es kein
Zurück sehr zum Ärger des
bauernpräsidenten der neue Proteste
angedroht hat die Ankündigung eines
Maßnahmenpakets zur Entlastung von
Bauern bis zum Sommer besänftigt da
offenbar nicht auch nicht die Opposition
Karl
Hinterleitner die Demonstrationen der
Bauern sie haben tagelang das politische
Berlin unter Druck gesetzt und heute im
Bundestag sollte es eigentlich um
Agrarpolitik gehen die Opposition aber
im allgemeinen Frontalangriff Friedrich
MZ nutzt die Gelegenheit für eine
Generalabrechnung mit der Ampel sie
bedienen ihre Klientel sie überhöhen das
ganze mit einem moralischen
Anspruch merken offenbar überhaupt nicht
dass sie genau mit dieser Politik und
die Agrarpolitik steht im Zentrum dieser
Politik dass sie genau mit dieser
Politik immer mehr Wählerinnen und
Wähler in die Arme der schrecklichen
vereinfacher von links und vor allem der
von ganz rechtsreiben die Regierung hält
dagegen die allgemeine Kritik sei fehl
am Platz wenn sie uns unterstellen dass
wir die Demonstrationen der Landwirtin
und
landwrte nicht gewürdigt hätten und als
Angriff empfinden würden dann greifen
Sie unter anderem mich und viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen an die sich
diesen Demonstranten gestellt haben die
versucht haben im Gespräch auch Lösung
zu finden und dann ging es doch noch um
Agrarpolitik die Vorschläge des
Landwirtschaftsministers ein Gesamtpaket
das Bürokratieabbau umfassen soll eine
gesicherte Finanzierung des stallumbaus
sowie steuerliche Entlastungen dazu eine
Zusatzabgabe fürs Tierwohl wenige Cent
mehr pro Kilo f würden bedeuten dass
unsere Landwirte Tiere Klima und Natur
zum Wohle alle besser schützen können
die Kürzungen beim Agrardiesel sollen
bleiben der Bauernverband hat für
nächste Woche wieder Proteste
angekündigt und auch in den Nachrichten
bleiben wir im Bundestag denn dort
wurden heute bei einem großen Thema
unserer Zeit Gesetze gundola verschärft
der Bundestag hat also ein Gesetz für
schnellere Abschiebungen von Ausländern
ohne Bleiberecht beschlossen
damit sollen abgelehnte Asylbewerber
künftig länger in Ausreise Gewahrsam
gehalten werden können damit Betroffene
nicht Untertauchen zudem werden die
Strafen für Schleuser erhöht die Union
kritisierte das Gesetz als nicht
ausreichend und der Bundeshaushalt für
2024 steht nach harten Sparbeschlüssen
und wochenlangem Ringen der
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages hat
den et fertig gestellt die Ausgaben
betragen knapp
477 Milliarden Euro und die
Schuldenbremse soll eingehalten werden
die NATO plant die größte Übung seit
Jahrzehnten ein Manöver mit rund 90.000
Soldaten ab Februar soll als Ernstfall
ein russischer Angriff auf das
bündnisgebiet geprobt werden das Manöver
ist vor allem an der Ostflanke der NATO
geplant auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum in
Davos hat Israels Präsident Herzog um un
Verständnis für die harte israelische
Linie gegenüber der islamistischen Hamas
geworben neben dem Bild des einjährigen
querbibas der jüngsten Geisel die noch
in der Gewalt der Hamas ist erklärte
Herzog Israel müsse sich gegen den
Terror
verteidigen der von den Ländern
eingesetzte Zukunftsrat für ARD und ZDF
schlägt eine Verschlankung aller
Strukturen der öffentlichrechtlichen vor
Doppelstrukturen müss abgebaut
kollegiale Geschäftsleitungen eingeführt
werden das Ziel ein effizienteres
Arbeiten sowie ein digitaleres
kostengünstigeres Angebot ZDF Intendant
Norbert Himmler erklärte das ZDF sehe
seine Strategie
bestärkt Schnee und Eis haben in weiten
Teilen Deutschlands erneut den Verkehr
behindert Flüge und Züge felen aus auf
vielen Autobahnen kam es zu
stundenlangen Staus wie hier auf der A3
im Siebengebirge immer wieder gelangten
Einsatzkräfte nur zu Fuß zu den Fahrern
um sie zu versorgen Kinder freuten sich
über geschlossene Schulen und am
Wochenende beruhigt sich das Wetter dazu
es wird sonnig am Freitag zunächst im
Norden und an den Alpen Schneeschauer
teils mit Gewittern sonst wechseln Sonne
und Wolken es bleibt trocken -3 bis + 5°
das Wochenende wird überwiegend
freundlich auf sonnig aber noch kalt ab
Montag wieder Regen Sturm und milde 5
bis
11° und wir haben jetzt noch weitere
schönere Aussichten morgen übernehmen
hier Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf und
später um 045 Uhr Christopher wehmann
mit unserem Update und jetzt viel Spaß
bei der zweiten Halbzeit viel Erfolg ja
Tschüss